ايش بتتمني بالسنه الجديده انه اروح على
تركيا وانا اخذ اغراضي
علشان نروح نرجع لايام العاديه عشان ناكل
حبشتكنات يا سلام ايش الحبشتكنات اللي ب
كبسي وعندهم
[موسيقى]
وكولا ان شاء الله بتتمنى نتخلص ان شاء
الله من هذا العدوان يعني ندمر بيوتنا ن
دمر حياتنا كلها ان شاء الله يا رب نعود
لحياتنا الطبيعيه وزي ما كنا عليه ونتخلص
يعني من كل هذا الهم واللي احنا فيه يا رب
السنه الجديده زي السنه اللي قبلها والسنه
اللي قبلها زي اللي قبلها هي هي ما فيش
الروتين هو هو يعني بده يطلع لنا شي جديد
مش حيطلع لنا شيء جديد ضلنا عايشين
مبسوطين ايش بنتمنى بعد رحمه ربنا
فيش اتمنى ترجع امن مستقبل اودي وارجع على
بيتي اه طبعا كل الناس دهم الحين يقولوا
ارجعوا على بيوتكم وبدي ارجع
ازحف تخلص الحرب بسرع وقت يعني عشان تخلص
الحرب ونجع على كل ضيو انه والض مخسوف
حالتي
حاله ايش زعلت اكثر شي عليه في
دارك
اخواني اخواني ايش صار فيهم خلاص ق ا
مانيش الا خير واحد صار ان شاء الله بكون
خير وامان وسلام ايش بدنا ن نعمل هيك بدنا
نعيش بامان وسلام يعني هي ح ه موت بهدله
احنا بدنا نعيش في استقرار وفي امان عننا
والصغار بدنا نعيش في امان ونا صغار بدنا
مترب
بالحياه 100 في بتمنى من الله عز وجل انها
تزيل هالغمه ونرجع على بيوتنا وتخلص
هالحرب على خير هذ مش حرب ه تخلص الاباده
على خير يا رب وما يجعلنا يجعلنا ما نفقد
حدا بعد هيك يا رب انه كل الناس تعيش
بامان احلى حاجه في الدنيا الامان وهدت
البال اتمنى لهم السلامه اتمنى لهم يطلع
من هالكابوس
هيك بكل جمال بكل حياه حلوه ان شاء الله
ربنا كريم بتمنى كل سنه ترجع زي ما هي
والحرب خلص على خير
و بتمنى كل اغراض يرجعوا زي ما هم والحرب
يخلص اتمنى الشي الجديد اللي اشتريته يرجع
زي ما هو ايش هو
احكيلنا فستانه و وطقم عندي طقمين جداد ا
وكله زي ما هو نفسي
يرجع